dc si si si
aujourd'hui nous allons là à la
rencontre de rémois va
d'abord chauffeur-livreur également
peut-être l'ensemble ne touche pas à mon
poste
raymond abou a décidé ce soir de se
confier à ses blessures car où va cesser
lure
rémois bout nous dira tout bonjour
raymond bonjour
merci d'être avec nous je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas vraiment jeu merci d'être
avec nous rubens et moi qui vont
renverser alors raymond
vous êtes vous êtes un des garçons d'une
famille de combien d'enfants alors j'ai
trois soeurs trois soeurs qui s'appelle
séverine avec sandra et elodie vous est
l'aîné de la famille non je suis chez
tommy lee jones celle ci sert d'armé une
petite surface adverse si vous avez une
grande soeur ce
vraiment vous on s'en fout de ce genre
dans un an
bien que très vite d d d d études de
quoi alors moi j'ai fait de jeu de cette
rue des études de sape et 3 techniques
je pensais que ces ordinateurs et
finalement c'est d'électricité rien à
voir avec les ordinateurs et vous avez
arrêté j'ai arrêté l'école à 15 ans
justement c ap ah oui vous êtes dirigés
vers quoi ensuite bah manutention un
balai et balayer un entrepôt d'accord
comme ça à villeneuve la garenne dans un
entrepôt de boissons
ces blacks pour des boissons et des
cannettes
c'est quand je voyais mon papa faire
j'étais chauffeur livreur nous rebat
était chauffeur livreur j'allais avec
lui à chaque fois qu'il y avait une
sortie scolaire ou le mercredi ou
pendant les vacances de juillet août
j'allais avec lui dans le camion et je
me faisais quand je serai grand je veux
faire ça et footballeur professionnel et
il est chauffeur livreur
c'est vrai que vous avez embrassé un
moment une carrière de footballeur parce
qu'ils étaient il a joué un très bon
niveau je crois vraiment gt ça
[Rires]
j'ai fait j'ai fait 7 ans au paris saint
germain 2 ans avec 94 admis la
génération et à la crise est passé pas
de rupture de ligament rien pas de juste
vu un manque de talent
dire en 2001 au monde il faut partir
maintenant et là vous avez pris votre
camion et vous avez hélas j'ai fait mon
camion j'ai continué à livrer vous
livrer depuis combien de temps
maintenant ça fait 30 ans mois de mai le
4 mai ça fait 30 ans je rentre en 92
dans la boisson
cataldi aussi mais on n'est pas ça
la très vite donc vous servez vous a
livré et très vite on se rend compte que
vous avez quand même une personnalité
particulière et qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous êtes vous êtes tourné vers les
médias ou bien ce que sont les médias de
son univers mais alors moi comme j'aime
bien le dire s'est jamais les médias qui
se tourne vers toi à moins d'avoir un
gros coup de chance et petit j'ai été
recruté pour faire des castings de films
très petit jeu refaire ip 5 avec yves
montand le dernier film en même temps il
m'avait il me connaît jean baptiste
clément à colombes il était venu me
chercher un mec en moto qu alli toi tu
faut que tu fasses du cinéma ensuite
j'ai raté casting vip et 5 c'est un
petit de ma cité qu'il a réussi ses
coûts salle qui est dans la rue mais un
film c'est un petit ma cité qu'il a eu
il a eu le casting lui après j'ai été
recruté pour faire david lansky avec
johnny hallyday j paul roll non je ne
sais pas pourquoi chez paul roll ensuite
pareil c'était dans paris je marchais
dans paris rue marbeuf avec ma moment et
il ya un mec qui vient voir qu'il faut
que tu fasses un film avec jacques
doillon le petit criminel et oui je
passe le casting du petit criminel j'ai
pété prix
[Rires]
route et
j'aspire à ce qui s'est passé je
continue à travailler je me suis levé
tous les matins pour prouver à mes
parents que j'allais être quelqu'un de
bien je vais pas être un drogué j'avais
pas être un voyou que même en venant de
là où je viens on peut faire des choses
bien si on a envie si on reste équilibré
dans sa tête moi dans mon quartier ça
vendait de la drogue savander du shit du
matin au soir on m'a proposé de faire le
chouf pour mille francs la journée en
cinq jours je pouvais faire mon moi on a
proposé également d'un amour
dans un cas s'aligner sur des shoots
c'est pas le bon coup
toujours rien il ya quand même les
quêtes
imaginez caracas a mis en joue
ça fait une heure et demie clé condé
fout la gerbe et gucci pas vu j'ai pas
vu mais j'ai pas vu alors ensuite le
déclic
c'est la radio si une rencontre ouais
c'est la radio c'est la radio et j'ai
toujours voulu faire de la radio match
et
encaissé la radio c'est d'abord je
traîne devant les halles et radio je
vous démarche vous pour faire de la
radio je démarche fondée voici donc si
gentil avec julie raynaud et jean pierre
foucault j'ai sorti de la radio est en
train de livrer deux restaurants pepita
et sa vie qui était en face de chez rcm
et je le dis sans moi de la regarde les
spas en galère là dedans sans moi de là
il m'a dit je vais te sortir de là
j'étais barré entre marange et au
téléphone
et après on a eu en producteur qu'ont en
commun laurent thibeault qui était à
l'époque avec os et donc j'ai fait des
trucs avec cauet et après il m'a dit
anna va quitter rtl va venir sur virgin
radio et je vais te prendre pour faire
des filles dans la rue avec cyril
hanouna je dis bah c'est génial et puis
ça s'est passé là de fil en aiguille si
le début donc bon abri t on à fait
délicieuse showbiz avec ses travers ses
excès
passés quand je faisais de la radio avec
cyril hahn hadj avaient pas droit
d'aller en studio j'étais toujours le
mec de l'extérieur c'est dehors j'ai pas
d'alliance dire un problème de co2 de 2
12 heures
c'est je dis souvent laurentides où on
avait dit je ne te mets pas inventé je
te mets pas autour de la table parce que
tu t'es pas prêt et tu es tu vas te
cramer avec cyril hanouna donc il vaut
mieux que tu restes en extérieur et que
tu nous fasse rire d'or avec des défis
dehors si je te mets à l'antenne avec
cyril tu vas te cramer et ça marchera
pas et je suis resté dehors quand j'ai
quitté la radio en avril avec vous
donc je vous ai dit je m'en vais parce
que ça me plait pas tu m'a dit si tu
t'amuses pas faut partir la radio
s'arrête en juin début avril j'ai dit
georges il ya de nombreux chroniqueurs
cette sérieuse histoire j'ai dit ça me
plaît pas et il m'a dit tu m'as dit pas
mais sur la tête de ma mère qu'on se
reverra et on fera des trucs ensemble
j'ai dû ça c'est des conneries ces
conneries qu'on raconte on fera jamais
rien c'est mort je suis encore passé à
côté du train après le psg je laisse
passer la radio en fait je vais finir
dans mon camion et un jour tu m'appeler
jeter sur l'autoroute il m'a dit viens
faire touche pas mon sport était 16
heures 15 g 10 mai jamais fait de télé
moi oui c'est pas grave tu entends
plateau tu dis que tu as perdu un stylo
tu t'assois et tu fais touche pas à mon
sport tu parles comme tu parles dans la
vie de tous les jours et c'est comme ça
que j'ai fait de la télé avec estelle
denis j'avais henri leconte à côté de
moi j'avais daniel riolo j'avais raymond
domenech c'est qu'est ce que je fous là
et puis voilà
[Musique]
quel est aujourd'hui votre votre
avenir de votre carrière moi j'ai pas de
carrière mais si basque aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que voilà vous avez savez
certaine aura dans le métier beaucoup de
gens pour réclame
ce qu'aujourd'hui ça ne donne pas de
souvenirs mes qualités déclic alors là
j'ai pas de souvenirs les jeunes filles
des trucs fous on a fait en radio c'est
vrai que c'est des fois ça marque
j'allais chercher le matin on n'avait
pas eu l'idée avec laurent thibeault
d'aller chercher les stars en camion
maintien et les mecs attendait un taxi
et j'arrive en camions montés en camion
tu ces trucs là c'est des trucs de fou
un jour tu vas le chercher laurine
lendemain tu vas chercher worlds apart à
leur hôtel les mecs qu'ils attendent un
minibus un vrai nom à l'école a donné à
monter dans lequel ils étaient trop
nombreux j'en ai mis deux dans la cabine
à l'arrière avec la marchandise les
worlds apart non il ya plein de trucs
marrants elle est vraiment plein de
soucis une aventure incroyable
or 26 un truc de fou moi je dis je t'ai
dit j'aime pas l'interview ça fait vingt
minutes que je suis dessus la gamme pas
les interviews du coup j'annule télé
loisirs mercredi aussi ce besoin
d'apporter les loisirs c'est la famille
poulter c'est très émouvant franchement
c'est pas du tout ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
parce que moi j'aime pas parler comme ça
là je ac 1-2 mon rythme à carte sécu
alors quand tu dois parler alors
la fonction c'est dingue à l'histoire
des noms c'est fou c'est vrai c'est fou
et cette année elle a été vraiment
encore plus folle parce que cette année
on a vraiment fait ce qu'on voulait ici
là vraiment c'est ce qu'on voulait moi
je sais cela là ça fait 6 7 mois on ne
prépare pas l'émission fait rien enfin
les collectes oui mais
non je parle de la liberté la liberté
elle est magnifique tu sors du plateau
tu viens pas pour moi on est là on sort
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment fou en
fait on n'y croit pas quand on regarde
la télé quand on parle de famille tp
c'est une famille n'y croit pas j'ai
l'impression que vous en foutez un peu à
du tout
je crois pas mais quand on est dedans
c'est vraiment un truc bizarre en fait
c'est fou entre une visée avec ses joies
ses peines ses lacets engueulades ouais
mais je suis un coup de gueule ses
portes qui claquent
et c'est vrai c'est foot et c'est ça a
cessé ses dépens des voitures
aujourd'hui je suis heureux parce que
j'étais pas programmé pour ça moi
j'étais programmé pour pas pour voir
tous ces choses-là en faites pas pour
pas pour aller dans des restaurants où
on a été pas pour aller pas pour monter
dans 100 grammes et pour ne pas manger
j'étais programmé à une vie comme mes
parents en fait j'étais programmé une
vie d'ouvrier j'ai toujours cette vie
d'ouvrier mais n'étaient pas programmés
pour que le matin les gens soient
contents de me voir quand je descends de
mon camion raymond s'il te plaît on peut
faire une photo jetez pas programmé pour
que les gens arrêtent leur voiture en
plein milieu de la rue je t'ai vu passer
je suis fait demi tour je veux faire une
photo avec toi fais une vidéo pour ma
mère fait j'étais pas programmeurs
ressort autant de messages sur un centre
d'hamouma ce type la vérité c'est vrai
j'ai non c'est vrai j'ai livré 25 ans 28
ans de ma vie dans l'anonymat et j'étais
pas programmé pour ça en fait quand je
regarde je me dis c'est avait livré les
français qui chaque matin pour leur
permettre de boire à leur soif et vous
aujourd'hui c'est les français qui vous
vie livre de l'amour mais c'est vrai ça
va
vous faire c'est un petit peu votre
votre moteur votre essence l'amour des
français
aujourd'hui raymond est ce que vous avez
déjà songé à arrêter un de vos deux
métiers ou chauffeurs livreurs ou ici
chroniqueur est ce qu'à un moment vous
êtes dit faut que je fasse un choix
est-ce que ça a été difficile il ya eu
un choix à un moment donné on avait
parlé ici m'avait demandé au public a eu
un choix c'est très difficile c'est
difficile de faire les deux métiers
c'est difficile de partir à cinq heures
du matin d'être bon dans la livraison
est d'être gens ici de soir en ayant
très peu de sommeil et c'est difficile
mais je peux pas me plaindre de la
chance que j'avais des millions qui
voudraient être à ma place avoir deux
taffes et être heureux de cette villa et
de dire je rembourse de crédit de ma
maison plus vite j'ai accéléré les
choses à une vitesse à une vitesse folle
donc je me plains pas mais c'est vrai
que je me suis posé la question de me
dire lequel des deux métiers tu vas
arrêter déjà vous arrêteriez quoi
franchement j'ai toujours dit que
j'arrêterai la télé moi je te dis
[Rires]
non mais serena chili j'ai toujours dit
que j'arrêterai la télé mais c'est quand
j'hésite à l'heure j'étais au périgée un
remords c'est ne pas avoir fait le pg à
fond je travaillais déjà quand je joue
au psg arrêtait envie d'essayer de faire
la télé à fond en arrêtant un peu le taf
6 oui moi pour ça faudrait que j'ai un
contrat de votre part
la sécurité je vous donne un conseil de
vieux briscards de la télévision
continue à livrer
non mais et il le sait vous en avait
parlé avec votre autre patron mais le ca
ma patronne situe pas très sympa asus
mls mal et à l'est elles mêmes crânes à
la rencontre real est magnifique ce que
c'est vrai qu'on a un petit peu la garde
partagée de rien
mais c'est vrai nom la vision david
rossi avec votre patronne et qu'elle
vous avez la nuit et moi je vous avais
le jour dire une chanson de patrick
bruel
moi j'avais jour qu'il allait livrer
même le jour de kippour
[Musique]
jamais le jour s'il te plaît ma série
monaco 12 mois à cacolac
et longtemps
cette fois ci donc aujourd'hui tu étais
heureux moi je sois je suis au journal
satirique dirige plus vers la télévision
je suis très fatiguée mais je suis la
petite lucarne
non parce que je vais garder mon métier
ça me semble s les pieds sur terre moi
j'aime bien sûr à chaque fois il ya des
débats pourquoi je prépare pas les
émissions parce qu'en fait j'ai des gens
qui me parlent dans la rue dès le matin
et toute la journée je parle avec des
gens donc j'ai en fait j'ai pas besoin
de préparer les émissions j'étudie ponge
un nom les genres les gens soutenaient
que les gens sont super content moi je
t'avais proposer plein de fois de venir
et les gens sont super contents de nous
voir ils sont super content c'est leur
addition de la mission mais je n'ai pas
d'accord avec toi hier j'étais d'accord
il ya bien sûr tu es vachement bien